>>It goes in this way, right?
>>Dea: I like to take
APs and Honors a lot
because it gives me
extra points on my GPA.
I have Computer Science Programs
first period and Physiology
for second, and third period
I have AP U.S. History.
>>Narrator: Dea Flores is very busy.
>>Dea: Fourth period
I have AP English.
Fifth period I have Math Analysis,
and after school, I have track.
>>Narrator: Instead of
going to her local school,
Dea commutes across town to
Bravo Medical Magnet High School
in East Los Angeles.
>>Dea: I didn't want
to come to Bravo.
I wanted to go to a different school.
And my parents, they forced me
to come here, and I hated them
for it for, like, a couple of months,
but then I understood
they were right.
As a Blue Ribbon School, it is a
very great educational program.
>>Alan, you're my guinea pig?
>>I'll be your guinea pig.
>>Narrator: Dea is
excelling at Bravo.
She recently designed an experiment
for her physiology class
using biofeedback equipment
and video games.
>>Dea: Well, I came up with
the hypothesis that people
who play video games more might
actually have a lower stress level
than people who didn't.
So I started asking people, "Do you
consider yourself a gamer or not,"
and then I would test them.
>>So this electrode is going to
be measuring your brain waves,
so I'm going to put one
electrode on your forehead
and one electrode on your ear.
>>Dea: It was the same game on
the same device for every person.
>>Alan was actually pretty stable
through the whole thing, I guess,
because of his familiarity
with the game.
Diana -- this is her practice
-- when she started hitting,
her stress level would
start to go down.
>>Dea: I gave my presentation
at the science fair,
and I thought because I didn't
have a solid conclusion,
it wasn't a valid experiment.
It turns out, I guess it was.
I got first place in the
category that I was placed in.
>>Exercise can actually
reduce stress.
>>Right.
>>How could that work?
>>Well, that's something I still
want to test because I still think
that athletes will have
a lower stress level just
because they have an
output for that stress.
Luis: [Subtitles]
>>Dea: They come to parent
conferences all the time.
They take my grades very seriously.
They were like, "You're very smart.
You just underestimate yourself."
>>See, it won't hit it.
It doesn't reach.
Something's wrong with the arm.
>>Dea: I guess they
think I'm a good student.
>>Narrator: For more
information about what works
in education, go to Edutopia.org.